when you hear the people that support
and don't support you how do you process
that so first things first I want to get
very very clear that Logan Paul is
absolutely not really a tool of the
Matrix he's a bought and sold individual
with no soul he doesn't stand up for
anything and he doesn't mean anything he
says he gets pieces of paper from Susan
or whoever else telling him what he's
allowed to say on his channel to retain
you believe that 100 not only do I
believe he's proved himself he will
flip-flop on any issue he can be bought
and sold the dude's a [ __ ] Logan Paul
is a [ __ ] and I will say that here
publicly if anyone wants I'll fight him
for free the guy's an idiot no money
needed nobody Logan Paul doesn't believe
any of the things he says Logan Paul is
a man if you ever were unfortunate
enough to consume his content I get sent
clips of it all the time by people
mocking him as soon as something comes
out whether Terry style is wearing a
dress whether it's uh little Naz
twerking on the devil whether it's this
he just sits there and goes yeah this is
great yeah this is great he is a talking
piece he is the mouthpiece for the
agenda